As in my home
when the wind took the fire to the O'Briens I
I Knew I need to do that thing that
People wonder about their whole life
Decide what should take from a burning building
Objects
Memories
Items that are tangible
These are our artifacts our
scars
Emotional physical
We live our lives and ask what do we leave behind?
Why don't you tell me how you came across this
Beautiful ring seems valuable, I don't know about that, but it is to me though
What do you want from your grandfather
still be something,
box of love letters, diaries, lives lived.
I raised my family here, and you know what?
It's home
You can tell everybody that I died as I lived, in my childhood home.
You're a puzzle little, bro.
It's just hard for me to understand what this all means to you. This is your space, not mine.
Things are not the same as they were before things have changed.
You don't have to go back to that house, it's all taken care of.
The house is the last place you saw her, every memory she has, it's in here.
Love, it maybe all you have left.